you dare enter this house
well yeah
[Laughter]
uncle Joey hiccups up his Friday the
19th of name the month is moving [ __ ]
quickly understand me as far as what
happened yesterday it happened yesterday
today is [ __ ] today it's a
whole new set of rules you don't even go
back to get [ __ ] momentum you
understand me
everything's a shaming like you know
what we move forward we smoke our with
we write our goals and somewhere another
we make it [ __ ] through
let's [ __ ] you know it's Friday all
right and you gotta be tip-top Magoo you
can't have nothing on your mind you
gotta be ready to swing dick and give
our [ __ ] toothpicks with a Nazi
helmet on she's at the end of the day
don't [ __ ] Malley understand me
you're gonna get up today you don't go
to work you're gonna write your goals
you're gonna go to school whatever the
[ __ ] you did and that's it it's the
[ __ ] weekend next week
half these morons are gonna be walking
around yeah Memorial Day potato salad so
this is your time to [ __ ] steal like
a [ __ ] sandwich next week there's one
of those weeks where everybody's walking
around a small motor they don't know
what to do you know for the week and it
gives a [ __ ] about the weekend
[ __ ] like you and I have lived
for today anyway it was a [ __ ] about
June 8th I don't know what the [ __ ]
gonna happen in June 8th I'm telling you
it's gonna have may 19th I'm coming out
the box like a [ __ ] savage with my
tooth to do Ted do I got a little
jujitsu today I got a meeting I got a
voiceover and then can I guess what
[ __ ] I gotta put on a suit and go
to school [ __ ] dance who's better
than uncle Joey huh
can you imagine me at the school dance
met with these four five year olds whose
little [ __ ] what are you gonna do
them you don't say it had to be a
comedian I gotta be a savage if I gotta
be a father that's the beauty about life
you get to wear a couple different
[ __ ] hats dry your [ __ ] cool but
enough is enough with the [ __ ] Joey
we got perennial we got the man with no
label this is the [ __ ] you don't they
call this eyeball shadow one of your
eyeballs are gonna [ __ ] shatter they
want you to call the emergency room 20
minutes before you [ __ ] smoke this in
case your eyeballs just [ __ ] shadow
this monster here what is this
this is perennial og I gotta butter so
I'm saving I'm gonna show it to you guys
next week it's a bun like this [ __ ]
big but you got to see the bottom of it
it goes underneath into the tree I that
listen don't get me all fired up on a
Friday I'm saying but the one eyed you
put together an envelope for me gotta
find just choke a meal we are weed for
the [ __ ] weekend
ain't no comedy tonight and guess what
[ __ ] they know Cali tomorrow night
this is [ __ ] the family uncle Joey
[ __ ] stakeout weekend
riten family jiu-jitsu and that's
[ __ ] it I'll be back Sunday night at
the store oh don't be dope ready to
[ __ ] go you follow me because of the
Emmis you got to take time off you gotta
[ __ ] see what the [ __ ] is going on in
life
no well Trump leaked Mattel who gives a
[ __ ] about Trump Lee commentary I don't
give a [ __ ] about mother and she I told
you [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
mental midgets right now that's turned
into a [ __ ] soap opera of life that
you don't need it's a real reality show
gives a [ __ ] all you need to know is get
up [ __ ] them steel with three hands put
something away in case this [ __ ] case
the [ __ ] Isis comes over you got
yourself a little cave to hide out with
tang you got some [ __ ] white bread
and that's it that's that this patrols
out of your head
you wanna get caught up in that [ __ ]
program ahead make my [ __ ] guess back
together they ain't worth it get going
up in yourself that's you need to get
caught up what's in your [ __ ] mind
what are you gonna do today
whose [ __ ] throat you're gonna shove
your balls down because you're a [ __ ]
savage you understand you have to impose
your will whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do you want to be a plumber you want to
be an architect get up [ __ ]
ain't nobody gonna knock on your door
and give me the perfect life you follow
me everybody thinks the perfect lights
gonna come don't be envious get up and
do something about it I'm saying like me
I get up every morning I ride a little
bit my snow a little reefer
I plan my [ __ ] around me I know what
I want I know where I'm gonna be at
every [ __ ] minute
that that's a type of [ __ ] [ __ ] I
am I need to know where I'm gonna
[ __ ] be every [ __ ] minute I got
this whole [ __ ] situation mapped out
because again a man without a plan is
not a man
Nietzsche let's smoke some of this [ __ ]
with no [ __ ] label understand they
call this the man with no name I've been
through the desert with a horse with no
name it's good to be out of the rain in
the desert they can't remember your name
cause there ain't no one for to give you
no fame the [ __ ] reflex working Jack
the eyeball of death look at the [ __ ]
head - on fire today don't miss a
[ __ ] beat but anyway you got a good
week ahead of you and that's it
the podcaster up and Brendan shop is
ready to rock him from the church who
else am I gonna [ __ ] drink a protein
shake - a little right and then by
eleven o'clock I'm gonna hit drill class
I'm gonna go for it today and I'm gonna
hit the regular class I'm gonna do a
little tactical fitness and that's it I
got a run to a [ __ ] audition and I
said my days to Kushi boom saw Joey
what's with the [ __ ] area be sparked
that [ __ ] Savage
oh there's the best part of my day when
I get here to smoke a bowl of death with
you [ __ ] believe that not
everything else is background music all
these [ __ ] Hollywood [ __ ] I
gotta bump into I don't give a [ __ ]
about them they can write themselves on
fire but you [ __ ] this is
what's crack-a-lackin' right here
[Music]
anyway the church is up both of them
enjoy them
Thursday night next week the Iowa House
one hour I'm just working I have no
material I think it's ten bucks to get
in even if you just come up smoke a
joint and we [ __ ] around take some
pictures that'll work too we got the
church Monday great guests Wednesday
great guess and that's all the [ __ ] you
need to know right now the only thing
you need to know is you're gonna go out
this weekend gonna keep your eyes open
ain't I do the best you can and by
Monday [ __ ] these [ __ ] when
they're all thinking about potato salad
and we're gonna take the ski jet out go
[ __ ] your mother
you're [ __ ] grinding it so next week
BAM there you don't always remember why
we'll be sleeping you're creeping you
follow me and that's it and that's that
I love your [ __ ] with all my
heart without you [ __ ] I'd have
nothing it's a family we're gonna [ __ ]
and take over don't worry about nothing
all right I love you guys happy [ __ ]
Friday tell him or to suck you dick